hi I'm Lupita Nyong'o and these are my
five favorite horror film
so first is Paul so guys Paul so guys
was the first horror film that freaked
me out and I was a little girl going
there here and that gave me sleepless
nights the babadook
I loved first of all the whole babadook
Dook Dook thing and it's not very
sophisticated reason to love it but I
liked that it was this psychological
thriller wrapped in this you know kind
of like ghosts in your closet story and
I also really appreciated that we didn't
see too much of the babadook and so you
spent a lot of time just kind of
creating the monster in your head okay
this one's hard martyr's it caused me
the most like psychological harm and for
that I pay its respects I don't
recommend anybody watch it because it's
a tough one
Jordan Peele gave me these 10 films to
watch for in preparation for us and so I
was doing my homework and that one came
with enter at your own risk in his text
and then he recommended I don't watch it
after he recommended I did watch it and
then I said well Jordan because you said
I watch it and now you're telling me not
to watch it guess what I'm gonna watch
it and so I dared myself to watch
martyrs and then I watched it and I
wrote to him and I said I should have
never done that and you should have
never recommended I watch it in the
first place his interview with the
vampire considered a war film yes yeah
and I don't even really remember what
it's about I watched a long time ago and
I remember that the vampires were very
beautiful
and I like that they were eye candy rad
Pitt Tom Cruise eye candy
train to Busan train to Busan is
extremely visually beautiful and I'm not
keen on zombie films but this one the
heard of this film is a story between a
father and a daughter that is just so
precious and we never lose track of that
storyline and that arc in the midst of
all the craziness going on and just it's
just such a sophisticated zombie film
and each character all the ancillary
characters are specific and rich and
every time you lose somebody it costs
you you know and I really love that like
investing in a whole group of people and
then having them just dwindle down to
the very last one it's just such as such
a remarkable story
[Music]
[Music]